Oh shit.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't even realize I... I wasn't even connected.
Sorry.
It was... the food was really good.
That's my... that's my only excuse.
The food was too good.
Um, yeah, I had to loop because it was like a... what was it?
It's like... it's like... it's like...
um, oh my god.
It was like some bread thing with like... it was like smoked salmon on top of it.
And it was really, really good.
And like, it's one of my favorite places right now.
Um, that I order for like breakfast slash lunch stuff.
Anyway, let me take a bite out of this too.
I also ordered a croissant.
There's a lot of bread.
But, um, no, it's not a sandwich.
It's like...
Okay, let me...
Let me look.
I'm gonna be like... I'm gonna be loading in real quick.
Let me see what it is.
I won't say what it is exactly.
But it's like...
Oh, tart... tartine.
Tartan?
Is that what it's called?
Um, it's like smoked salmon tartan.
I think that's how you pronounce it.
Um, but it's so good.
It's like one of my favorite places to order at the moment.
Um, no, it's like T-A-R.
T-I-N-T-E.
Wait, is that how you spell it?
T-A-R-T-I-N-E.
Sorry.
It's a smoked salmon tartan.
And it's like my first time ordering something.
Not my first time, but ever since I ordered that, I've been like, um, I've been like ordering it quite...
Like, not like regularly, but like at least like once a week because it's just so good.
Like, it's just really, really good.
Um, Kasha's dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your very first super chat too.
Hi Toki, second time ever getting to participate in your stream.
As soon as the Dragoon won at loop number five, would that be possible?
I mean, that means I can eat more of my croissants, so sure.
Loop number five!
JK.
That's five.
That's ten Canadian dollars worth of loop number five.
I just want to take a bite out of that and see how it tastes like now that I finished my bite.
It's time to actually stream like, no, why Toki, you know, you know why, you know, because you guys, okay.
You guys want to know exactly why?
Because I ordered a drink and they didn't give me a fucking straw.
So now I take my anger out.
On you, Dragoons.
Because I don't have a straw for my drink and I have to drink it like a fucking caveman.
I'm going to take their anger out on you.
It's going to be a paper straw.
I don't have straws in my new apartment.
Okay, I know it's like new, new, even though I've been like living here for like two months now.
I don't have any straws, guys.
I have forks.
I have knives.
I have spoons, but no straws.
You know what's even worse?
They gave me a fucking, they gave me a fucking fork.
And I'm like, why do I need a fork?
I'm eating a sandwich.
Like everything I ordered, like stuff that I eat with hands.
I was like, why did they give me a fucking fork, but no straw?
That's the only thing that I needed.
I'm just, I can't believe it.
Yeah, so like, um, that's why I'm mad.
That's why you don't get an intro, you don't get intro number five.
Hmm.
That's why I own metal straws.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dude, metal straws taste fucking nasty.
I know it's like for the environment and everything, but like, it's just, it's like the metallic, it just makes things taste metallically.
And I'm like, I don't fuck with that.
I know, and also paper straws suck.
Why did we destroy, why did we destroy a planet so fast that now everything has to be out of paper metal?
Why can't, why can't that be the next generation?
Why?
I'm sorry, that's really fucked up.
I, why do we have to go through with this?
Is that fair?
Don't keep me off.
We are the next, this is exactly why.
Being the final generation sucks.
The board of boomers sucks.
The board of boomers sucks.iec Yikes, I'm so sad.
We destroyed our planet way too fast that it has to affect us.
Because, like, okay, the reason why I think it's not fair, is that I grew up when we had plastic straws.
But now we have to transition to either metal straws or paper straws.
The next generation, they never grew up with plastic straws.
So they don't know what they missed out on.
They think paper and metal straws are the norm.
So they don't know what it was like with plastic.
They don't know.
They don't know what it was like.
And they don't understand.
So they don't know what they lost.
But we do.
We know what we lost.
They know what we lost.
I'd rather be born in the next generation.
Than be born in the generation where we had plastic straws and now we can't have them anymore.
You can still buy plastic straws but they're so...
I don't really fucking...
The price is like expensive.
Or they don't have it.
Because they're like, you know, we're trying to save the environment.
Which is justified.
Like we gotta save the planet.
But still, it's just...
I can't believe I had to grow up in a time where I have to miss plastic straws.
Anyway.
Stop feeding us microplastic.
Well, yeah.
Anyway.
Life update.
Life update, guys.
Sorry.
I got a message from Surefour.
Because...
I got...
There was like this...
There's like a tournament thing for Deadlock.
And they were like, do you want to be captain?
And I was like, I don't play Deadlock.
I was like, I don't play Deadlock.
I don't play Deadlock.
And I asked Surefour.
I was like, Surefour, do you want to...
Do you want to join this...
Me joining this tournament is dependent on if Surefour joins my team.
Because I was like, I don't play it.
So I know he plays.
And then, anyway.
His first response was...
Have you even played Deadlock this month?
I will!
On tomorrow!
He's like, have you even played at all this month?
He's like, I will!
I will tomorrow!
He's like, I will tomorrow!
Anyway, me joining the tournament.
Really, heavily depends on if Surefour says yes.
If he says no, then I know I'm fucked.
Because I don't know how to play this game.
Anyway, life update.
Yesterday was hell.
So, right after the stream, I did errands, um, I did errands until, until I got home at 8pm.
I, oh my god, if he, if my, if my bank teller watches my stream right now, I fucking hate you.
Okay, I, I, there's the, okay, so, like, every time I walk to the bank, I always get this specific bank teller.
Like, not always, but, like, 80% of the time, 80% of the time, he is my bank teller, because whenever I get there, um, he's there working at the, at the station, you know?
So, like, I always see, like, I always have to go to him, but, like, oh, anyway, he knows that, like, I'm, um, he knows that, like, the business is, because, like, I go to him for the business account and everything.
So, like, I don't know if he'll look it up, but if he...
If he does, and he watches me, I don't like you.
Please let me have another bank teller.
I really don't like you.
Because, like...
The reason why, the reason why is that...
Oh, like, I think he knows, because I was, I was, I'm always so annoying.
I'm like...
Like, the reason why...
Because, like, he, like, makes it so much more complicated than it should be.
So, I was doing a wire transfer, right?
I was doing a wire...
I was doing a wire transfer yesterday, and then I was like, okay, I want to do this wire transfer.
And then he was like, why don't you do a bank draft?
And I was like, a bank draft?
No, like, fine, I can do a wire transfer.
He's like, no, no, you should do a bank draft.
Because it's, like, like, because, like, it's already close by, like, the neighboring bank that you're supposed to wire transfer to.
It's close by.
And I was like...
Oh, okay.
And then he was, like, prepping the bank draft.
And then I looked up the neighboring bank.
And it was closed!
And I was like, why the fuck did you suggest it?
Thank God I looked it up.
Because, like, I was like, okay, let me look up where it is.
And it was, like, closed.
And I was like, are you fucking serious?
Because he's like, it's cheaper.
Like, you don't have to pay a $50 fee if you do a bank draft.
And I was like, no, no, that's okay.
I don't, I don't care.
Like, I'm willing to pay the $50 fee.
Because I just want to get it over.
With, like, it's fine.
And he's like, no, no, it's just easier and cheaper.
And then he was, like, pushing it.
And I was like, okay, I don't want to, like, alright.
And then, like, and I was like, okay, I want to do a wire transfer instead.
And then, like, and then, like, he was like, wait, what's the business name?
And I was like, oh, isn't it in the email?
He's like, no, no, it's not in the email.
Is this a personal account or a business?
And I was like, well, it's being sent from this guy's email.
And it says his name.
So, maybe it's personal.
So, I got really confused.
I was like, I thought there was a business name in there.
And then I, like, texted the person I was supposed to wire transfer to.
And they're like, yeah, it's in the email.
This is the business name.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Like, I was just like, why the fuck did he keep saying that wasn't the business name?
And then, at that point, because he was like, okay, can you, like, sidestep?
And then I'm going to help the person behind you because it's taking too long.
And then, like, you know, when it's, oh, when I finish with this person, I'll get you back in the line.
Okay.
I was like, okay.
And then, like, and then the other bank teller, there was another bank teller there.
And then he was like, oh, hey, I'm free right now.
And I was like, oh, okay.
And then I literally gave him the wire transfer info.
And he just, he didn't ask anything.
He was just, okay, it's done.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
I was like, I had to answer so many questions.
I was like, because, like, he wasn't asking me about, like, oh, hey, where's the business name and everything.
And then, there's another step, too.
I was like, oh, okay, um, I want to, I want to change the address on my account because, like, I don't live there anymore.
And I recently moved.
And then he was like, oh, do you have any personal documents?
And I was like, um, well, I have my bills that, like, my bills, but they're all, like, I can print it.
I have it online.
And he's like, oh, is it, like, oh, you don't have any, like, personal documents, like, physical documents?
I was like...
Well, I just moved, but, like, I do have, like, rental agreements and, and, like, uh, the rental agreements and, like, bills I'm paying right now, like, BC Hydro and everything.
But they're all, like, digital, like, on email, either email or, like, um, from the BC Hydro stuff.
And then, um, and then he was like, oh, uh, well, we can't, sorry, it has to be, it has to be, like, uh, physical.
And you have to change, so you have to change the address on your, on your ID.
And I was like, what?
But my ID is a different address.
I was like, but, but my ID is an address from, like, five plus years ago.
Like, like, it's not even the same address that's registered at the bank.
And then I was like, how is that possible?
The address on my...
My bank account is different from the address on my ID.
But the address I'm changing at my bank account, I want to change it to my newest address.
And he's like, I don't know how that happened.
And I was like, what do you mean you don't know what happened?
Like, that doesn't make sense.
Like, I was like, wait, that doesn't make sense.
Anyway, I need to update the address on my ID.
I need to update the address.
I was like, the hell is that open?
Like...
That's my ID.
But yes, I will be updating my ID address.
I never had the time.
And I got away with it for so long.
I'm just like, this is not a fit.
Anyway.
I fucking hate this guy.
Like, I get him every time.
Like, not every time, but like 80% of the...
80% of the time, 80% of the time, like, I'm like always, oh my God.
I'm like, oh, I always get this guy.
And like, he's been so fucking annoying.
I...
He doesn't explain things.
He doesn't explain things well.
And like, I had to like walk back several times.
I hate it.
Anyway.
That's over with for life update.
But I also had to do other stuff for errands and everything.
So like, I was so tired yesterday.
I literally was doing errands until 8 p.m.
And then I got home.
Also, like, I'm gonna get a dog trainer next...
And like, either next week or like in the middle of October.
Because...
Because that has been a little shit recently.
And like, I need the dog trainer to tell me what to do.
I need the trainer to tell me what to do.
Okay.
So, so I need, okay.
For some reason, he's been very aggressive to like, to like other, uh, to like other dogs.
Um, he's been incredibly like, not like, he doesn't like try to bite them.
Or anything.
He was, he's just been like, he's just, whenever he sees another dog, he's just goes like, like, he's really loud by the way, like the other dogs are just minding their own business.
And he gets incredibly aggressive.
And so like, so that's why I'm like, that's one of the reasons why.
Um, that's one of the reasons why.
So like, I'm trying to figure out like how to make sure he doesn't do that anymore.
Cause I'm like, cause, cause I'm just like, please, please.
Please, don't, please, I need you to calm down, I need you to calm down.
Um, so like, I'm going to see if I can get the dog trainer to help me with that.
And also, yesterday he's been, okay, I think I, now I need to supervise him when I get him toys.
I need to supervise him when I get him toys because, um, I need to buy him, I had to buy him a new dog.
I need, I had to order him a new dog bed today.
Which fucking sucks cause I literally got him a new dog bed, um, last week.
I got him a new dog bed last week and, um, I was like so excited cause it was super cute.
Like not cute, but it was like super, it seemed super comfy and, uh, and like, and like he could like burrow in it and stuff cause it was like a little, like a burrow bed.
Um, and then I got him a new toy today.
Um, and then I went to sleep.
Cause I, when I was doing errands, I was like, oh, I want to, I want to, you know, grab a little toy for dad.
Cause like, I was like, oh yeah, like he could got like, you know, a little present for after a long day out of home, like out of the apartment.
And then, and then I like, I went to take a, take a nap.
I want to take a nap.
I woke up.
Not only did he destroy the fucking toy.
Where there's like fluff.
Everywhere on my bed, on my bed, in my bedroom floor, everything I went out cause his bed is like, he's like his dog bed was outside.
I went out and there was fluff everywhere on his dog bed.
And then there was holes everywhere on his dog bed.
And I was like, what the fuck?
It was the first time I saw him.
Absolutely.
Destroyed a dog bed.
Cause there was literally holes everywhere.
And I think he got way too excited about destroying his dog toy that he like, he like was like, you're next.
He was like, you're fucking next.
And he went half on the bed as well.
So, so lesson learned.
I'm gonna, I need to supervise him when he has a toy so he doesn't fucking destroy his dog bed.
No, I did, I was like, I was like, I was like, dad, no, this is bad.
No.
I even took the stuff.
I was like, what is this?
And then he like sneaked under it and he sneaked under my own bed.
He sneaked under my own bed right after.
I was like, you can't hide from this.
You can't, you can't, why you, you know you fucked up.
He knew what he did.
Like every time, every time he knows he got in trouble or like he knows like, oh no, she's gonna give me a bath or something.
He just hides underneath my bed and I can't do anything about it cause he's underneath my bed.
Anyway.
No, it's actually crazy.
Like there's holes underneath the dog bed.
Like how there's holes underneath the dog bed.
There's holes on the side everywhere.
It's literally everywhere.
I am like, I'm, I'm so impressed.
I'm like, I'm so impressed that he managed to do that.
I'm like, what happened?
I was just taking a nap!
Anyway, that's another life update.
Okay, any other life updates?
I wrote some stuff down.
Oh yeah, I did yesterday, I know you guys might have seen it already, because I saw people already talking about it.
But, yesterday, LMDN me asking me to join an Among Us lobby filled with a lot of people.
I told him I can't join exactly at that time, because I was like, I have a stream.
I have a stream today, so I said I'll join.
I'm not gonna rush my stream, I'll join.
But it'll be after my stream's over, and then maybe I'll be there at 3 or 4pm.
That's what I told him, because I was like, I already have commitments.
But like, I know like, oh my gosh, what are the list of people that he gave me?
It's LM, Sykuno, Valkyrie, Allermouse, Mysayoshi, Blau, Mii, Huun, Foolish, Chatterbox, Selpid, Ettoz, I don't know who that is.
Janet, and Ludwig.
So like, I said that I'll join later.
Like, when I finish my stream, and I zoned out and like, you know, relax a bit.
And like, you know, relax a bit.
And then I'll hop by for a bit.
I won't... I don't know how that... I won't be streaming it.
I won't be streaming it, because I have like another stream at 11pm too.
So, um...
So it's...
Mostly it's gonna be like, where's JokeyBrain?
It'll be like, where's CarmenSanDiego?
But where's JokeyBrain?
So yeah.
There's that.
Who is Ettoz?
I actually don't know.
I know everybody here, but...
I don't know who this is.
Oh, he's a YouTuber.
Oh, he's a French YouTuber?
How the fuck did he get in here?
Wait, he IS a French YouTuber.
He's a French streamer.
Oh my god!
Wait, he's pretty big!
I'm sorry for hoo-ing you.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, weehoo, weehoo.
I didn't know.
I don't follow the French side of YouTube.
Anyway, so yeah there's that.
Let's get into it because it is... we've been talking for 30 minutes now... whoops, okay.
Let's put up the game.
I'm super excited to play this game.
I hope the company's not mad at me playing this game because it's definitely not going to be child-friendly.
Because I remember in the past when I would ask if I could stream this game and then the company actually replied back in email being like, no.
So I mean, now that I'm an indie, obviously we can stream whatever we want now, but I hope they don't stop me.
I really hope they don't try and stop me.
That would be embarrassing.
I'm super excited.
This is actually one of my... wait.
Why is it not... oh there it is.
Oh.
Oh my god, it goes straight in.
I'm sorry!
I didn't press it because it starts right away!
Oh my god, I didn't realize it would start right away.
Holy shit.
Freddy fish in the case of the missing kelp seed.
Alright, there's no sub to... oh it's Puppet!
Jason!
Oh my god, it's the Puppet!
Oh my god.
Puppet goes to the zoo has to be the number one.
My favorite game.
Puppet goes to the zoo.
Let's bring up Freddy.
Okay.
Oh, there's Grandma!
Keep gaming right here.
No!
Not the treasure chest!
Ow!
He must have seeds in him!
Who steals from Grandmama?
Wait, can I not invite Luther?
He's a little... I don't like him.
...butter and jellyfish sandwich for your journey.
I'll say it right now.
I put in my description, but I hate Luther.
I think I'm a Luther... I'm a proud Luther auntie.
He is nothing but trouble.
No!
Not Luther!
He is nothing but trouble!
All he does is... all he does is cause shit!
And he doesn't help... he doesn't help anybody!
He...
He always gets us in trouble.
Grandmama should not let... let Freddy hang out with Luther.
Like, all he does is cause trouble and...
He's a menace to society!
Anyway, for those who don't know...
Luther is innocent.
So, for those who don't know about...
Freddy Fish, it's like a point-and-click adventure.
And like, this is basically like...
For kids who don't have access to the internet.
Oh, hey!
We have no food?
Wait!
But what about the peanut butter and jelly sandwich?
What about the peanut butter and jelly sandwich?
OH MY GOD!
MY GRANDMA KEEPS THE LAST FOOD IN HER...
IN HER CABINET!
NOW SHE'S GONNA STARVE!
Well, she's already old, so like...
That's fine, I'm a growing fish.
You gotta help her, Toki!
Anyway...
For those who don't know...
Like, the humongous entertainment games...
They're basically like children point-and-click adventures back then.
And like...
You can buy...
I know like, my parents would use to buy them in bulk...
For me...
Um...
At Costco...
Cause that's where all the games are.
That's where all the children games are!
You're either a jumpstart kid...
Or a humongous entertainment kid.
I...
I wrote this in chat...
But jumpstart children...
Jumpstart games are for fucking nerds!
Humongous entertainment games are for gamers!
I played both.
Oh, then you're a nerd and a gamer.
You're a nerd and a gamer.
Because jumpstart games are all about...
Reading!
And math!
And science!
Humongous entertainment is about...
Problem solving!
It's about street smarts!
Not nerd smart!
So...
Um...
But yes...
It was...
Um...
They did a lot of them.
There was Spy Fox.
There's Freddy Fish.
There's Putt Putt.
There's Pajama Sam.
I think my fave...
I think I...
Um...
I actually like...
I think this is the...
This was the very first...
Uh...
Humongous entertainment game I've ever played.
Um...
So...
The Freddy Fish...
And the Search for the Missing Kelp Seeds...
Was the very first...
Uh...
Game I've ever played.
For...
Uh...
From Humongous Entertainment.
But my favorite ones was...
The...
Putt Putt Goes to the Zoo.
Because I replayed that a lot.
And also...
Pajama Sam.
And the...
Which one was it?
It's the one where he like...
Was trying to find his like...
Um...
His...
Trying to find his missing comic book.
Oh...
What was it called?
Was it the comic book?
Or the...
The...
The bit...
Oh...
Or is that two different ones?
I forgot.
There's two Pajama Sam ones that are really, really good.
But I don't remember the title names.
One where he goes under the bed.
And then he...
Uh...
He has to like...
Find a monster or something.
Like...
He has to feed the monster underneath his bed or something.
And then the...
There's the food one.
Yeah.
I remember.
Anyway...
Um...
I don't know...
I don't know if like...
I think like Freddy...
I think they're also like different...
Yep.
You can...
There's replayability too.
That's one of the best parts too.
Is that...
A lot of the games they main...
Has like...
Replayability.
And then...
So like...
There's...
Sometimes they'll have like different mini games.
And different like quest lines.
Um...
But the endings are the...
The endings are the...
Is the same.
But like to get to the ending is different.
I don't know about the first one.
I don't know about Freddy Fish and the Search of the Missing Kelp Seeds.
Is...
Just...
It has like different replay...
It has replayability.
But like...
Um...
I know like...
The...
Pajama Sam one.
And like the...
All that.
There's like...
Um...
It's non-linear.
Yeah.
I don't know what the final version is.
Which was pretty crazy for a children's game.
There was a lot of...
Oh, dude.
Fuck this kid.
Please don't...
Report my stream.
Humongous Entertainment.
I love your games.
I'm a big official...
We're literally in water, Luther!
Don't be stupid!
How can you not loop-de-loop?
Please don't report us!
Oh, no!
Hello!
How are you?
I'm not here to play Mario.
I'm here to play Nintendo.
Luther!
This is my grandma's treasure!
Luther, you greedy fuck!
All the fish?!
What do you mean, all the fish?
Like, is grandma fucking feeding the entire population in this town?
Where do you have all of my homies?
All the fish are gonna die and we don't find...
Okay, I didn't realize that was the odds here.
We do not need to hear Luther.
No, we do not need to hear.
Hey, Sakuno.
Come on, we gotta find that bottle.
Oh, we're shark bait.
But sharks don't need kelp seed.
I don't understand.
Sharks don't eat kelp?
Oh, unless they want to monopolize the kelp seeds so then they can fatten up the other fishies.
So they can, by fattening up, they'll have more food.
So you can, every time you click somewhere, there's like new stuff here.
Cause that's the, there's the blue fish right here.
And then there's, there's another fish right here.
God, I hate Luther.
You're so dumb.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Why are you Freddy's sidekick?
Freddy deserves so much better.
Freddy, Freddy deserves so much...
Anyway, I brought up the sound a little bit.
Oh, I love all the, it's so pretty too.
Like the animation of the pixel animation and everything.
Like they put so much thought into this.
I wish they made new games.
I really do.
But like, I don't think children would play this.
It'll just be nostalgia bait.
It'll just be, it'll just be nostalgia bait.
Oh no, is your kid stuck?
Don't worry, I've got you man.
Luther, can you do anything right?
Is that your son?
Can he not swim out?
Where is he?
Alright, let's find this man's lost child.
Alright, do we get a reward for this?
Guppy, Guppy, Guppy.
Could you please help my Gabby?
Yes, Mrs. Halibut.
Alright, we gotta help the mom.
Hello?
Oh shit.
Wait, I remember this.
I was stuck here because I was such a stupid child.
Please help me.
Alright.
Get him out of here.
What are we going to do?
Don't worry Gabby.
We just need to find a bigger board...
to pry the rock off your fin.
Wait, how did you get stuck here?
Why can't we just cut the fin?
It's obviously just a fin that's stuck here, right?
Please help me.
He doesn't need that end of the fin.
It grows back, right?
I still got it.
It's a red purple.
Don't worry Gabby.
We just need to find a bigger board...
to pry the rock off your fin.
Why don't we just cut it?
Just rip the fin off.
Like, it's literally just a purple.
That'll do for it.
Like, he's not going to bleed out if it's just a thin fin, right?
The fin is just like skin.
Right?
Sorry, I don't know fish anatomy.
I do not rip the fish's fin back.
Don't be such a baby.
It grows back.
Please help me.
The rock.
Suck.
Don't worry Gabby.
We just need to find a bigger board...
Alright.
We just need to find something to pull him out.
I remember I could never...
I had the hardest time trying to save this child.
Because I kept coming back and I was like...
How the fuck do I get this guy out of here?
Oh, hey look.
Jumping seaweed.
Yay!
Did you guys see that flip?
Child?
Are you okay Luther?
Did you see the flip?
Little kid!
Hahaha!
Wasn't that cool?
That was sick!
Woah!
Gabby's stuck.
But he's okay.
At least he's okay.
Don't worry.
Your child's not dead.
So you'll be fine.
And if he is, you're a fish.
So you can have like a lot of them.
Another treasure map!
What's in it?
The note says...
Go to the deep canyon.
We found another...
A deep canyon?
Where's the deep canyon?
There's so many arrows!
Oh, I found another board!
It's a wooden board.
I can use that to help the child.
Oh, the sea urchin!
That's money!
I remember!
We found a purple sea urchin.
Oh my god!
The sea urchin!
Okay, so sea urchins are money chat.
The beach is up there.
Alright, let's go to the beach.
Luther!
Luther, help!
He did something!
I don't know why you hid all those bottles.
I can't believe they just left the money on the floor like that.
Just sitting there.
Where are you, the kelp treasure?
Well, if you can't find that treasure chest, you're gonna have to answer to the squid father.
The squid father?
Not the squid father!
Oh my god, this was...
Finding Nemo stole...
I can't believe Finding Nemo stole from Freddy Fish.
Hahahaha!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe Finding Nemo would do such a thing.
Hello crab.
What's wrong?
Oh me oh my, oh me oh my.
I must get out of this cage.
Please help me get out.
And I'll give you my fishing pole.
Your fishing pole?
Wait!
That means you're also eating other fishes.
That means I could be next.
I don't know, maybe we shouldn't save him.
Yeah, why can't I just take the...
Wait, you're right.
Why can't I just take the pole?
Yeah, he can't stop me.
He's literally in jail.
Oh, is this a mini-game?
Do I win anything from this?
Who's in here?
Okay, okay, I was gonna be like...
Guys, this is where my FPS career started.
I actually don't remember this game.
Please.
What is the fucking hitbox?
Okay, it's not me, it's the hitbox, guys.
All three buckets of jellyfish left.
We can leave when the arrow flashes.
Let's play again.
Do I actually get anything?
Why can't we eat the jellyfish?
Isn't that also food?
I'm pretty sure, like, you know, we don't need to eat just kelp.
Wait, isn't that kelp right there?
To my right?
Or is that... No, that's kelp.
Yeah, this is kelp right there on the rock.
Can't we just harvest that?
Alright, Freddy!
You fed them all!
Get ready for some more animals, Freddy!
Can't we just feed... Can't we just harvest this kelp?
Okay, let's...
Go get them, Freddy!
That's fine.
This is so easy.
It's like this game is made for children.
Where's the difficulty scaling?
It's dead kelp.
It's not the same.
Okay.
Stop using logic!
All I'm seeing is that this is affecting my immersion right now.
Wait, there's fishes now?
See, I told you!
I told you the fish eat dead kelp!
I told you!
What do you mean the fishes are gonna starve?
These fishes are clearly fine!
They're...
They don't need grandma's kelp!
Alright, Freddy!
You have all three buckets of jellyfish left!
Let's play again, Freddy!
Fish don't buy everything.
You're a higher class fish.
Oh yeah, sorry.
This is like...
Those fishes are not the upper class.
These are the middle class and below fishies.
They don't deserve the kelp that me and Luther have.
Freddy!
There's a jellyfish left!
They're wild fish.
Freddy, it looks like the fish are hungry too.
Well, they're still...
The commoners are approaching.
Let me see if we can get to a hundred.
Alright, let's see.
Infinite ammo.
I don't understand.
Like, what happens to my bucket if they get close?
Do they just raid the buckets?
More points than others.
This is like those, like, videos where we are taking advantage of, like...
You know those, like, YouTubers?
TikTokers?
That take advantage of the homeless people for, like, uh...
For, like, content?
This is me and I put, like, three buckets of, like...
Three... Like, I'm just throwing food at them.
Am I a bad fish?
Am I...
Oh my god, am I...
Am I a bad fish?
Am I...
Monetizing their...
Their misfortune?
Am I Mr. B?
No, we're not there yet.
We're not there.
When I become a...
Maybe a millionaire, then maybe I can be Mr. Beast.
You fed them all!
Let's play again, Freddy!
I fed them all!
Watch out for the zigzagging octopuses!
Wait, is there octopus now?
Wait, how long does this go?
How many do they have?
Oh, they zigzag now.
Mr. Doki.
Guys, did you hear about the newest...
It's crazy.
And, like, within, like, two... four months...
Like, 2024 has been the fucking craziest year for, like, streamer downfalls.
Like, there's so many streamers that fell from grace within 2024.
It's actually crazy.
Wait, is there more than just the octopi?
Wait, what happened now?
Well...
There was the Moon Moon thing.
And then there's, like, Mr. Beast.
And then there's, like, uh...
You know...
The Moon Moon thing was fucking crazy.
I'm like, no!
That's too close!
That's too...
Oh,
no!
Yeah, that shit was insane.
When...
Because, like, Moon Moon has been a content creator for, like...
He was a...
I remember Moon Moon when he was Moon Moon underscore O-W.
So that shit was insane.
When I...
When I read the...
The logs or...
I read the logs.
I...
I couldn't fin...
I couldn't finish reading the logs.
It was...
It was too much.
I was...
I was like...
Oh, my God.
Wait, the fish is...
Holy shit!
He's so fast!
He's so hungry!
He's...
Oh, my God!
He's so fucking hungry!
They are wild.
They are fucking wild.
Anyway...
The newest Mr. Beast thing is that apparently he's blacklisted from Las Vegas or something.
Because he's trying to do this reality show that's like the Squid Game.
And then apparently the working conditions for...
The working conditions for it was so bad that, like, they had...
They blacklisted Mr. Beast from ever working with them.
But, yeah!
Yeah.
Apparently, like, contestants were literally, like, having to go to the hospital and everything.
Anyway.
We'll let this crab die.
I guess.
Where do I go?
Which one is which?
There's no signs anywhere.
When this happened, I found out, like, this week about it.
Both of those things.
Oh, yeah.
And then the Lunchables shit was funny, too.
Well, it's not funny.
But...
Don't worry.
I will definitely help Gabby.
Even though he looks like...
Even though he looks like Luther, I will help him.
Oh, yeah.
The...
What was it called?
What?
The Lunchly or whatever.
Oh, hey!
Oh, is that key for the crab?
The fact that they're, like, it's...
It's healthier than Lunchables.
But then...
You can't get through the shrimp net unless you got the super duper duka buka poly gizmo.
The super duper poly gizmo?
You can't get the super duper duka buka poly gizmo.
Luther, you can literally fizz through it!
You give me a clock.
Why do you want a clock?
Is he flashing me?
Look in the junkyard.
Luther!
This is your one time to redeem yourself.
Luther, this is literally your one time to redeem yourself.
Luther, you fit in the hole!
Luther, you literally fit in the hole!
Please, do anything!
Nice clock.
This sounds like a scav.
Okay, I got the key.
Alright, sir.
I got the key.
I need your fishing pole.
I'll get you out of the cage, fiddler crab!
Are you surprised this jellyfish game was Luther's idea?
Zane, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Get her down!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright, give me your fishing pole.
Bro, just throw it!
You don't need it.
Bro, if you throw it, what's closer?
Lucy.
Thank you, Mr. Crab.
Yay!
I could have stolen it.
I could have literally stole the... Oh no, I don't want to play this game anymore.
No, I didn't mean to!
I didn't mean to!
It was so close!
Lucy, get me out of here!
Is he giving the chat?
No!
Okay, I'm gonna... Alright, go eat my bucket.
999.
It's like giving a chat.
Oh, he is!
Oh my god, please, I can't leave!
I have to wait for them to eat the bucket!
But yeah, it's actually crazy how within four months, like...
I think, like, literally he released a video.
Four months ago, or three months ago, where he had, like, so many YouTubers and streamers from Twitch and YouTube participating in, like, the streamer games.
And then, literally, like, the fall from grace.
It's actually crazy.
And also, like, the Lunchable Lunchly stuff was, like...
Because I'm like, how is Prime healthier than Capri Sun?
Like,
I couldn't, like...
Okay, you can just... You can try it.
You can try it.
I'm trying to say, like, okay, it's almost similar to Lunchables, like the crackers or whatever.
But then, I'm just like, how is Prime, like...
I don't feel like Prime is healthier than Capri Sun.
Isn't Prime, like, filled with, like, sugar?
Like, you can argue about everything else, but, like...
Oh, hey, let's go... Let's go explore a dead...
Let's go to a fish cemetery, Luther.
That'd be so cool.
Oh, and harvest the bone!
Let's fucking go!
Go, Freddy!
Go!
The electrolyte.
Yeah, but I'm pretty sure Prime has, like, lots of sugar.
Alright, let's go.
Let's leave now.
Yay, Luther!
Let's play in the cemetery!
And brave rob somebody's remains!
Let's go!
Yeah, it's an energy drink for children.
Which I don't think it's really that healthy.
I think it's sugar- There's no way Prime is sugar-free.
Don't- I'm gonna Google that right now.
I'm just thinking, there's no way.
Is Prime sugar-free?
There's no way.
There's no added sugar in Prime?
What makes it so sweet?
Oh, artificial sweeteners.
Oh, isn't that worse?
Isn't- Isn't artificial sweetener worse?
I think I- we're confusing the term healthy with less terrible.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, so it's sucralose and inosito and something potassium.
I have no idea what that is.
I can't believe it's sugar-free.
But I feel like...
I feel like artificial sweeteners may not be as safe- Okay.
Okay.
I love how- Okay.
I like how- I like how this one was like, it's not as- It may not be a safe alternative.
Especially for kids.
Holy fuck!
Okay.
That caught me off guard.
No way.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um.
Okay, let's- let's- Let's go back to Freddy Fish.
Alright.
Here you go.
It's time to save you.
So your mom can- Please help me.
So your mom can reward me with some money.
Ling, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Toki, I'm kind of feeling happy today.
And it's because I see you streaming today.
Okay.
Thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay!
We saved the fish!
Mommy!
Gabby!
My Gabby!
Thank you both.
You're welcome, Mr. Halibut.
Of course.
Mrs. Halibut.
Please, this is the urgency urgent for saving my Gabby.
Yay!
We're rich!
Hey, Mrs. Halibut.
Wait, you said some.
You gave me one.
Hey, I think you miscounted.
You said some.
But you gave me one!
You gave me one!
I remember as a child, because I was so stupid and didn't use my problem-solving skills, my game plan going into, like, because, like, when I first started playing these games, my game plan going into these games was just click everything until something happens.
I would click everything because I had no problem-solving skills whatsoever as a child growing up.
I still don't, but, like, now that I've chat to problem-solve for me, like, it's a lot easier now.
It's a lot easier.
Yeah, keep clicking until something works.
Oh, I have... I got you something!
I wish I could get some sleep, Freddy.
But this shell, it glows all day.
It glows all night.
Oh, no!
I wish I could brave it for a shell that doesn't glow.
Oh, my God!
You know, this game was made in the 90s because, like, he's not using a can for a shell.
The pollution hasn't hit yet.
Hi, Herman.
You look pretty.
I wish I could get some sleep, Freddy.
But this shell, it glows all day.
It glows all night.
I wish I could brave it for a shell that doesn't glow.
Well, ain't you in luck, Mr. Crab.
Second Crab.
I got you a shell that doesn't glow!
I got you a new shell that doesn't glow.
The Radioactive Crab.
Freddy, Freddy, Freddy!
It's wonderful!
It's okay.
Back then, we thought radiation was really funny.
And doesn't cause, like, cancer.
Hey, you can use this glowing shell!
Thank you, Freddy!
But now we know.
Now we know.
Good night.
Good night!
We should hurry up and find the kelp treasure!
Yay!
We got a radioactive shell!
The funny... Oh my god, he's gonna have superpowers now!
Wait, who's here?
Welcome to King Crab's Castle!
There's so many crabs in this fish universe!
Radiation makes superheroes!
Oh yeah, you asked about the fire alarm earlier!
Yeah, it was a fire alarm test.
I just didn't know how long it was gonna go.
So that's why, like, I stopped the stream.
Because I was like, okay, it would be weird if it keeps going on for, like, 30 more minutes.
While I pull cards.
And people would be like, why the fuck are you pulling cards when you...
I didn't go downstairs, by the way.
I just... I... I just stayed...
I just stayed in my apartment while the fire alarm kept going.
I was like, it'll stop eventually, right?
Cause I looked outside, there was no fire trucks.
I didn't see, like, people downstairs.
So then I was like, okay, so, like, it has to be a false alarm.
Guys, I'm not... I'm...
Guys, I might... I might have a...
I might be fucked in life.
Wait, you know me?
Oh my god, you know me?
Am I famous?
Of course, I'm upper... upper class here in the fish universe.
What happened?
Wait, are we all depending on my grandma's food supply for the entire population?
I think that's not very kingly of you.
Like, I...
Oh my god, it's his mistress right here.
Did you see that?
Oh my god, his mistress is right there.
Mr. King, I don't think we should be relying on my grandma to... to fund the entire...
food supply of your kingdom.
No wonder I'm famous.
I'm literally, like, holding on to, like, this population's...
the population's life or death situation right here.
Grandma is the unauthorized cup supplier.
Only grandmama can supply the food.
Nobody else!
The potato famine!
And thus, I was responsible for the potato famine.
Alright, we go this way.
This way.
And then...
Oh yeah, that's where the king is.
You can see the crown.
Alright, before we go, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, chat.
Oh wait, there's more money here!
Wait, let me grab the money.
This is much more important than the bathroom.
Money is more important than using the bathroom right now.
Alright.
We're going this way.
I'll be right back, chat.
Wait, no!
Wait, I think there's a club nearby.
If I remember correctly, there should be a club.
We could go watch the club while I use the bathroom.
There has to be a club right here, right?
No.
God damn it!
Alright, you guys see the pit.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Dad tried to break in my room because he knew there was food inside.
Uh...
He knew there was food inside.
And the moment I came out of the room, he tried to rush in.
He's like, it's time!
He's like, this is it!
I can go in now!
I thought that you guys...
Oh, I thought that...
I'm gonna head over here first.
Alright, we're gonna go here.
He took his shot!
Oh, another sea urchin!
Yay!
More money!
I can't believe they would just leave money on the floor like that!
Hello, little starfish!
Hello, Mr. Starfish!
Class?
What?
You know what?
It can't be that difficult.
Like, this is a game for children.
But also, why am I getting taught right now?
Like, I didn't consent to being in this class.
Oh, that's so easy!
Three...
Twenty-three!
Look at that.
Quick maths.
Do I win anything?
Teacher, where's my positive enforcement?
Sixty...
Four.
Yay!
What is the sum of...
90, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15...
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15...
5, 1, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9...
95!
Very good!
Yay!
Guys, in my head, I cannot do 8 plus 7.
I don't...
I don't know what...
Oh, it's 20!
It has to be 20-something!
So it has to be 22!
I can't...
I don't know what 8 plus 7 is!
Oh, 63.
Okay, how is that advanced?
What is 64 minus what?
Okay, if that is advanced...
What is...
79.
If this is advanced, what is easy?
What the fuck is easy?
Minus 1 is in your pants.
2...
This is 5...
4...
5...
1...
4...
3...
It's...
4...
5...
15...
Minus...
7...
14, 13, 12, 11, 10, 9...
8...
It's 28!
28!
You're right!
Yay!
We've answered 7 questions right.
We did it!
Okay, I'm stopping.
I don't think he's gonna stop.
I did it!
Wait, I wonder how easy is easy?
How easy is easy?
I'm Mr. Starfish.
Your math teacher for today.
Welcome to class.
Guys, now you guys can tell why I almost failed math.
How many seahorses do you see?
3, 6, 9, 10, 11, 12.
Oh, he just count.
That's easy.
So like, we don't even get numbers.
You just learn how to count.
Another problem.
Is it just seahorses?
How many fish are there?
4, 5, 6, 7...
Okay.
All right, so easy is literally just counting seahorses.
Wait, then what about...
What about North Sea Seahorses?
Four.
This is hard.
Doki, I'm blind.
Of course this is hard.
How hard do you want...
How...
What's medium then?
Some medium.
Is medium only single digits?
What is the difference between...
Wait, this is so much harder.
Oh no, this is four.
Four.
Very good.
This is visual learning and I've got very good at the visual part.
What is the difference between...
Okay, nevermind.
This is a lot easier.
I can't believe I don't get rewarded.
I don't get rewarded for this.
Where are my stars?
Where are my golden stars?
Guys, I need my immersion.
Can you give me gold stars for a good job well done?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine if Doki Bird plays Winnie the Pooh Home Run Derby, a kid's game.
More like hell in the form of baseball, especially when facing the torturous nightmares that are Tigger or Christopher Robin.
Oh yeah, I heard about that game.
I heard that it's like incredibly difficult for the baseball part.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what I'm excited about?
I'm excited about the Backyard...
What was it?
The Backyard Baseball?
Or Backyard Soccer?
Or Backyard Basketball?
That game was so fucking fun, and I think it's harder than the Home Run Derby.
Oh, I have a bone!
You want this little bone?
That's right!
It's your dead, dead mom.
He's basically Cubone now.
He's basically Cubone!
I mean, could be.
Holy shit, what the fuck is that?
He could literally be his dead...
It's dead mom.
We found it in the graveyard.
We grave robbed it.
Shoutouts to Cuba!
Oh!
Nice cock!
Clock!
Nice clock!
That's what I meant.
I'm PG.
Oh, there's a frog here.
There's some kelp.
We should be harvesting kelp while we're doing this.
You know what I miss?
Okay.
The one thing I miss about Japan, or like Asia in general, living in Asia, is the konbinis.
Or like the 7-Elevens.
Because like, the food you can get at the markets and everything.
And the one thing I miss the most is the egg sandwiches.
The egg sand...
Oh, it just doesn't...
I've been trying to chase the egg sandwich high in Canada.
But it's just... it doesn't... it's not the same.
It's not the same!
I got it!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's just not the same.
The egg sandwiches just doesn't taste like the egg sandwiches in Japan!
Oh, so that's why...
I didn't say no!
What?
It's a really nice clock!
Look at it!
It has numbers and everything!
Hello, would you like... would you like a clock?
A clock!
You're welcome for the clock!
You're welcome!
Nice doing business with you!
I got it, guys.
I got the clock.
By the way, I'm eating an egg sandwich right now.
That's what I'm talking about!
Egg sandwiches!
He said it was a great clock.
To tell time.
That's what clocks are for.
Alright, let us...
I think we have to go back there.
I wonder if this is a game where we get to go to the club.
It's like the club in one of the Freddy Fish games.
And then you get like free entertainment.
Alright.
I don't think I finished...
Oh yeah, did I finish this part yet?
I think I did.
Yeah, I did.
I did.
So we're going to the pit.
To the pit!
Where Bane was born!
Clocks over time?
That's true.
I used to wear watches all the time.
At school.
But ever since the iPhone came out, there was no use for watches anymore.
Luther, you fucking idiot!
Why do we ever let him do anything?
This is why I say it.
Freddy Fish needs better friends.
Freddy needs better friends.
If I was Freddy's mom right now, I would make sure he...
Oh, you're one of those moms.
It sure is scary down there.
Luther, my mom said we can't hang out anymore.
She says you're a very bad influence.
And I'm right!
This place is scary.
And I'm fucking right.
You are a bad influence.
I'm not the bottom.
I
have the glow-in-the-dark thing!
He must like it.
It's a glowing shell.
Yes, I know it's a glowing...
Oh wait, maybe a fish?
Maybe like I'll fish him out and then we kill him?
I fucking knew it!
Problem solving!
Oh my god, it's like this is a game for children.
I honestly, legitimately thought that we were gonna kill the fish.
We're gonna fish that fish out.
And then just chuck him out into the sky.
Into the beach so it dehydrates and dies.
It's literally self-defense!
He started it!
We're getting closer to the kelp treasure!
Yay!
Not the squid father?
Oh, clam up, sponge head!
You lost the treasure, so now you got to see the squid father!
Oh, please, boss!
Not the squid father!
The squid father!
That's right!
You messed up!
Did you guys know sharks and squids are Italian?
All sharks and squids?
Alright, where do we go?
I guess we go here.
There's holes there.
Yeah.
Back then in the 90s, everything was a Godfather reference.
Whoa!
The three caves!
Now no one gets past Eddie the eel.
Why not?
But we're looking for Grandma Grouper's kelp treasure.
If we don't find it soon, all the fish are going to die.
Yeah, and their blood is going to be on your hands.
Look kids, why don't you just get out of here before I have to eat you?
What?
But like, if all of us dies, you won't have anything to eat anymore.
What if I pay you?
And Urchin, if you want past me...
You're going to have to give me something better to eat.
You want my only sandwich?
That my grandma made?
With the remains of all the fish population food?
And if I give you this sandwich, I wouldn't be able to eat today?
Give it.
Yes, I starve.
Yum!
Grandma Grouper's famous peanut butter and jellyfish sandwich.
I guess I could let you pass.
Good luck finding Grandma Grouper's kelp treasure.
Oh, now, okay.
He's like, good luck.
Maybe now you won't starve if you do find it.
That's funny.
He's like, all right.
Well, now that I'm fed, I hope you guys get food later.
All right, we'll go this way.
Oh yeah, I think this is a labyrinth or something.
Oh, I have the glowing...
That's right.
First try!
The clue says the treasure is hidden in the sunken ship.
A sunken ship?
We will get the kelp seeds at the old ship.
I know.
You're right.
Why didn't we just feed him looser?
Oh, hey, there's the catfish.
The crab!
I thought I put the first bottle at the nexus.
But the squid father...
Or was the first bottle at the canyon?
Come on, sponge head.
There's dead fish next to him.
The squid father trusted us to hide the stolen kelp treasure for him.
Wait, why the fuck does he need kelp treasure?
He literally doesn't even eat...
He's not even a vegetarian.
I remember where the treasure is.
Come on, sponge head.
Wait, where is the treasure?
Oh, it's the sunken...
It's in the sunken ship.
Wait, did we...
Did we just skip?
I didn't finish exploring!
What treasure should be?
Aye, matey.
That old shipwreck has held...
How did we get here?
...so many treasures over so many years.
We're looking for grandma.
Good luck, mates.
Wait, I can't leave.
No, I didn't finish exploring!
No!
That old ship sailed through hurricanes.
I passed the point.
But I have five dollars!
I have five purple seers.
I have five dollars!
I didn't use my money!
Wait, this was when I was a kid.
It took me an hour to complete the sunken ship.
I remember actually crying at one point.
It's like I would cry too if I had to be stuck in the game for an hour.
Stuck at this point for an hour.
Grandma Grouper's kelp treasure is for everyone to share.
And besides, the window is closed and it's much too heavy for the crank.
We could crank open the window...
I can't believe it!
What am I going to do with my five dollars?
What?
Look, Luther.
Grandma Grouper's...
Oh, you can pause?
Game pause.
Okay, I can skip with escape.
Thank God.
I was going to be like, please, I don't want to listen to Luther talk again.
Do it, Luther.
I can't believe it.
Oh, Papa Coss is here!
There he goes!
Oh, there's my grandma.
Is she worrying about me?
Are you worried, Grandma?
Oh no, he's coming over.
They're coming over.
We gotta go.
I need to find the crank.
It's humongous.
That crutch might come in handy.
You know what I missed though?
I missed the beginning of the...
Because it didn't do the intro.
The humongous entertainment intro.
Wait, Papa.
Random dinosaur.
Oh, look at him.
Go, Skelly, go.
That's right.
You're fucking dead, but go.
Dance for our entertainment now.
You're stuck in purgatoria.
Dance for children.
You cried from that?
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, this is apparently their first game.
Yeah.
Is anything in here?
Hello?
I'm Phineas McFinn.
The finest sailor on the seven seas.
Arrgg.
There's just one word that says it all.
Arrgg when I'm happy.
Arrgg when I'm sad.
Arrgg when I'm good or bad.
Arrgg.
Arrgg to port.
Arrgg to starboard.
Arrgg from stem to stern.
Arrgg.
So simple.
Yo ho ho hum hum my chum.
Arrgg.
What might you say?
I can't hear ya.
Arrgg.
One more wave.
Bro, he's dropping the bars.
When will we get his 3D debut?
Arrgg.
The handle is broken.
Oh, hey.
Arrgg.
If you could find old Phineas another musical instrument.
I would gladly trade you this useless crank handle.
Arrgg.
You want...
Do you wanna...
Do you want this?
Arrgg.
Okay, we gotta find another instrument somewhere.
And starring Sam Miller.
Arrgg.
Starring Sam Miller?
Who the fuck is Sam Miller?
Arrgg.
Such a polite sailor.
Wait, no.
Not this way.
Arrgg.
I think there's like another way up top here, right?
Yeah.
I thought I came over...
Yeah, there we go.
I gotta go this way.
I can't believe it.
Wait, no.
What?
Oh, no.
Now I know why you cried.
Arrgg.
Oh, no.
Now I know why he cried.
Arrgg.
It's a loop.
Wait, maybe like...
Wait, she has a...
Oh!
Da-da-da-da!
Here!
Would you like this crutch?
Aye.
Me old crutch.
Thanks, matey.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
We got a guitar.
Now, I don't need this old mandolin.
This is where you cry.
You're absurd.
That's right.
I have problem-solving skills of a five-year-old.
That's fucking right.
Arrgg.
I did it.
I...
We're so proud of you, Toki.
My...
Oh, she can problem-solve like a five-year-old.
She's so smart.
She beat a...
She beat a game for kindergarteners.
The brain rod hasn't won yet.
Where's my gold stars, chat?
At the end of the game.
I want my gold stars for motivation.
I won't be sad.
But there's no string on your guitar.
He's lip synching.
He's playing from a recording.
Does that sound all right?
This isn't live!
I want my refunds.
I want my fucking refund.
That wasn't even a live performance.
Pre-recorded trash!
The scandal of the century.
Alright, let's see.
Time to put that in.
Okay, I'm so sad I didn't explore everything.
I'll never know what that five sea urchins are for!
Okay, there it is.
What do I do here?
Can I open?
Yay!
We saved the fish population!
Yeah!
Uh-oh.
No!
Yeah!
Equality for all!
No!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Toki!
Sharing is caring!
We all have the same amount of food for everybody!
Okay, who's gonna tell the squid father?
Guys, who's gonna tell the squid...
Hahaha!
I like how we just left and be like, well, we're not gonna tell the squid father, right?
Gangsters.
We all know gangsters love sharing.
Wait, it was for the theater?
I can't believe the bottle cut me out of the theater!
Yay!
Grandma, look!
I used our year's supply of kelp seed!
Freddy, you found the treasure!
We did it, Grandma Mom!
I saved your treasure, Grandma Cooper.
Okay, fuck off, Lucy.
Well, it seems pretty ugly little, but I figured it out.
I hate you.
I was very brave.
I will anti you forever.
I'm sure you will.
Hahaha!
This is why your parents left you at Grandma Mom's doorstep.
Shut up, Lucy.
And as a child, I had hated Lucy as a child.
And now, it's been years and I still hate Lucy.
It was never a phase.
Hahaha!
It was deep-seated hatred that's gonna go for generations.
Mr. Doki saved the ocean with a thousand plants and kelp.
Bless!
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What are they doing?
Oh, we did it!
Wait, we gotta go to the theater.
It's not over yet, guys.
Guys, it's not over.
We have to go to the theater.
We got it!
Yay!
Humongous presents!
Guys, I just wanna know what the theater is like, guys.
It's not over.
I need to know what the...
Oh, let's grab some money.
Alright.
I'm sorry for skipping the credits.
I need to know what the...
I forgot what the theater is like.
We gotta explore, guys.
I wanna know what the theater is like.
I remember it vaguely, but not really.
Hahaha!
The theater speed run.
Oh, that's the volcano, right?
Oh, I need a...
What do I put over here?
Do I put...
Oh, it's a sea urchin!
Oh, that's what I need the money for!
The theater is at the volcano!
Okay.
We gotta go.
Never skip credits again.
No, I need to find five dollars.
Five dollars again?
Okay, that's fine.
We're gonna go fast.
Okay.
That's three.
I can count because Mr. Starfish taught me how to count.
We did it!
Theater percent.
Let's go!
Hahaha!
We gotta get the money, guys.
We gotta be able to afford it!
Okay, we need two more.
It should be last two here.
Speed running chores.
Okay.
Okay, we don't care about the shark.
I think one was with the king, right?
I like how we went to the king to just be like...
I like how we just went to the king and he's just like, hey, um, we're sort of gonna die off because, uh, we don't have like any...
We don't have any kelp anymore.
Like, that's literally his purpose and the money.
Okay.
We need one more.
One more should be...
It should be...
It should be like near the clock guy.
Because there's like one for every area, right?
So there should be either there or...
Okay, I don't care about your son.
I don't care about your son.
Let's go.
We gotta leave.
There it is!
Yay!
Anyway, let's walk over the...
Hahaha!
Sidestep the bottom.
Let's sidestep the bottom.
Hahaha!
Yay!
Oh shit, there he is.
Don't talk to the stranger.
Hahaha!
Guys, we don't...
We don't talk to that stranger, guys.
Hahaha!
Alright, we'll grab the bottle just for now.
Okay.
And then we gotta...
Well, I'll go this way.
Whoop.
Hey there, lady.
Whoop, she's still stuck there.
Stepfish, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Guys, I hope I can keep this bot up.
Hahaha!
Hi...
I hope we...
Hahaha!
Okay, let's...
Okay, I wanna go to the volcano area.
I have five now, I think.
Yeah, yeah, I have five.
That should be enough.
I wanna know what the pearl is for, though.
Hahaha!
Oh, there it is!
Okay, but that doesn't matter.
We're here for the volcano.
No, I already put two in there.
So like...
We have one more left.
Oh, we fit!
Nice!
Okay.
Come on.
We don't use all because we fit automatically.
Oh, there's the volcano!
There it is!
The theater is over here!
The theater!
The live show!
I want to go watch!
Free entertainment!
Let's go!
Oh, it's at Augie's Magnificent Show!
This is a good way to call it here.
Welcome girls, boys, and fish of all ages to the great show under the sea!
It's us!
We've got some great acts here today.
Sure to make your gills quiver with delight!
So, put your fins together for our first fantastic performance!
Wait, I don't want that on the Marvellous Show!
I don't want to watch a fucking fraud!
Boo!
Looney Tunes did it better!
Not the frog!
Okay.
Get him off the stage!
Oh, it's Helga the Seeing Mermaid!
Oh, that's it.
That was three seconds.
The frog was faster.
What the fuck?
Boo!
Oh, Amazing Augie!
I heard it's pretty amazing.
What's he gonna do?
I paid five dollars for this!
Do you know how expensive sea urchins are?
Worst opera ever.
At least there's like six plus performances.
Wait, I can jam to this.
Lucvis von Basethoven.
What a rip-off.
Oh, Carpet Marina!
That's when you know this game is from the 90s.
Everybody had the lady with the fruit on top.
Woo!
Shake those hips, ma'am!
Shake it!
You get what you pay for.
Oh, the Flying Carp Brothers.
What's this?
They're just swimming.
They're just...
It's not that impressive when, like, they're just swimming.
Like...
Even a child could do this.
You're just swimming!
Oh, hey.
Versailles featuring Clovis P. Portoy.
What's he gonna do?
Is he gonna read to us?
What did I do?
Boo!
Swords!
What?
He didn't even fucking read!
Oh, Puffo the Amazing Expanding Fish.
Oh, is he gonna expand?
Oh, my God.
There he goes.
We're making fun of his biology.
Bump and Gump.
Holy shit, this is way more shows than I remember.
Oh, the clouds!
Yay!
Yeah!
Kill him!
That's just how it goes.
That's just how he does.
Bro is...
Oh, no, no!
Get Frank off the stage!
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
We did it.
We went to the theater.
It was not worth $5, guys.
The theater was not worth $5.
Hahaha!
I feel scammed!
I can't believe it!
Anyway, we call it a year.
That's so Lutheran to the volcano.
True.
But yeah, I'm really happy I get to actually finally play Ready Fish.
It's such a nostalgia.
It's such a blast from the past type deal.
This game, as a child, definitely took me a very long time to finish.
I remember it would take me like hours because I'm so stupid.
I couldn't problem solve correctly.
But there was always like super... lots of replayability.
I think we play another humongous game.
I definitely want to play the ones I never got a chance to play growing up.
Because I never got the actual CD-ROM for it.
There was demos.
Back then, Humongous Entertainment would give you free demo games in cereal boxes and stuff.
To give you a taste of what you could play and it would stop you.
Yeah, the demo disc!
Yeah!
So there were a lot of them that I never got a chance to play at all.
So definitely the next one.
I want to try one.
I want to try...
One of them that I never got a chance to play growing up.
But my favorite was definitely the Pajama Sam series.
Pajama Sam and Putt-Putt for sure.
I remember playing the Putt-Putt...
I played Putt-Putt Saves the Zoo so many times.
Because there were so much different scenarios you could do with Putt-Putt Saves the Zoo.
But yeah!
That was really fun!
Going through nostalgia and childhood stuff.
I had a great time just like going through like...
Just playing through my childhood.
You know what I wish they have?
I wish they have...
I wish they like put the Blue's Clues game back on Steam.
I'm really happy that the Humongous Entertainment games are on Steam.
But I wish that the Blue's Clues Treasure Hunt was on Steam as well.
That one game was so fun growing up.
I played that so many times with Steve.
Yeah, Blue's Clues Treasure Hunt.
I think that's what it's called.
It's called Blue's Treasure Hunt.
That was such a good...
That was...
That was fucking fire!
And then there would be like stuff from Steve where he goes like...
Blue's gonna do...
You can do!
And he goes into like...
And then he does the thinking chair and everything.
I'm this Blue's Treasure Hunt.
They're all abandonware.
Yeah, but I still...
I wish they could put it up on Steam and stuff.
Cause like...
Even though they're...
They're like...
Um...
I feel like...
I don't know.
I still wanna like support...
Support the people that made that game.
Cause it was such a big part of my childhood and everything.
It was just such a fun game back then.
Um...
Uh...
Felia!
Thank you for the farm!
Get the shits!
Thank you!
Sir Ken!
Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome!
But yeah!
I'm really, really happy I was able to...
Uh...
I'm really...
I'm really happy I was able to actually like play the game for finally.
Um...
And...
Cause I haven't been able to play in a long time.
Um...
Since you know...
Since I was a child.
Cause I never touched any of the...
I never touched any of the Humongous Entertainment game until like today.
It's been like so many years.
It's been...
The last time I actually played a Humongous Entertainment game was like I said when I was like a child playing it.
So it was really nice to revisit like nostalgia and stuff.
And revisit my hate for Luther.
If as a kid I...
If as a kid I recognized the feeling of hate for that stupid green fish.
Um...
That's when you know I hated him so much.
All that he did was cause trouble.
And...
He was a bad influence on Freddy.
Um...
But yeah.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching and going through memory lane with me.
Um...
I am going to chill a little bit.
I won't be in the Humongous collab right away.
I'm gonna chill and zone out.
But we do have another collab as well at 11pm with Restia and RPR for Apex Legends.
So...
Uh...
We're gonna be playing Rink I believe.
I mean I feel like we should because our team is pretty stacked.
So I feel like pubs would be like really boring if we played pubs.
But uh...
So yeah.
We're gonna be playing Apex Legends Rink.
Uh...
Later at 11pm.
So that'll be fun.
I haven't touched Apex in a bit.
So uh...
So I definitely need to warm up again.
Uh...
I definitely need to warm up a lot.
Ahhhh.
So I need to figure out if like...
I'm doing...
If I'm gonna do this deadlock tournament or whatever.
I've been getting so many invites to things.
It's actually crazy.
I...
I like...
I don't know.
It's such a new feeling.
I never...
It's always like...
In the past I always had to like...
Ask to be invited to things.
Or like...
You know...
Ask if I could be invited to stuff.
Or like...
Um...
If people wanna collab with me.
I always had...
I was the one to initiate.
So it's like...
It...
I feel so...
I don't know.
I think like I'm really happy that people are asking me to join things now.
Cause it's...
It's such a nice feeling.
To be asked for...
Instead of doing the asking.
But it's also like...
It's so hard to say no too.
Cause it's like...
I've never had so many of these opportunities before.
I've never had like...
So much of these opportunities.
So it's like...
It's so hard to say no.
Cause it's like...
Oh my god.
I wanna do it all.
You know?
I was like...
I was just like...
Oh my god.
I just wanna do it all.
Cause people were requesting me to join.
And I was like...
I feel...
I feel like...
Oh my god.
You want me to join you guys?
So then I feel like...
Oh that's so sweet.
So then I just say yes.
Cause I was like...
That's really sweet of you to ask.
But like...
For a deadlock tournament...
I have to think about it.
Because...
I don't know about deadlock.
Like literally...
If sureforce says no...
I'm gonna say no.
Cause...
My team is heavily dependent...
On like...
If sureforce is gonna join me or not.
Cause I don't know how to play deadlock.
Like...
I don't know how to...
And he's been grinding that shit non-stop.
He's like the only person...
I've ever met.
And I know...
Who's currently streaming it.
That's like a fucking gamer at that game.
Where's the Among Us collab?
I believe...
All the other people that are...
Most of the people that are in it...
Will be streaming it.
So let me...
See...
Look at the names again.
Um...
It is with...
LM, Sykuno, Valkyrie, Ironmouse, Masayoshi, Blau, Hewn, Foolish, Chatterbox, Cellbit, Itolls, Janet, and Ludwig.
So like...
Those are the names that are apparently in the Among Us lives.
But I'll be showing up later.
So I won't be showing up right away.
Because like I need to chill.
I need to relax.
Um...
Yeah.
He's a deadlock streamer now.
That's the only reason why I'm asking.
Because he knows what he's doing.
But yeah.
There's like...
A lot of tournaments.
And a lot of events.
There's so...
Like...
The next couple of weeks.
You're gonna see so many tournaments.
And events.
I'll be joining.
Because like I said yes to them.
And some of them are sponsored too.
So like...
So like it's gonna...
It's gonna be wild.
My schedule is sooo...
Packed.
It's actually...
It's soo fucking packed right now.
Next week is like...
I think next week is like...
There's a lot going on next week.
I know like...
Um, there's a lot of collapse next week.
And so, we'll see how it goes.
Anyway, um, thank you all for hanging out with me.
I always love hanging out with you guys, Dragoons.
And as, oh wait, before I leave, I wanna talk, I just wanna chill and talk a little bit.
But did you guys see the new anti-cheat in Deadlock?
Speaking of Deadlock, did you guys see the new anti-cheat in Deadlock?
Where apparently they turn you into a frog and they find out you're cheating.
The community can vote on either, like, banning you immediately or turning you into a frog.
And, like, force you to play the game as a frog.
And, like, what's fucking hilarious is that this update was supposed to be for CSGO.
Like, you're supposed to be turned into a chicken or something.
Originally, the first concept of it was originally for CSGO.
And then you were supposed to turn into a chicken.
And then the CSGO...
The CSGO players were so mad because they were like, I can't believe they released this...
They released this update on the anniversary of CSGO.
And I was like, that's so fucked.
I was like, oh shit.
And sighed.
They literally took something that was for that game.
And it ended up fucking on the anniversary.
Oh my god.
That's so sad.
I was like, that's so sad.
It's their anniversary.
And you grave robbed the corpse.
You took their only thing they wanted.
Was a better anti-cheat.
And you gave it to Deadlock.
I...
That's so...
That's so sad.
I feel so bad for them.
I feel so bad.
This is why I found it.
But yeah, I thought it was funny.
But also a little sad.
A little sad there.
And...
And yeah.
FireRed moves by the death.
King is dead.
And I think it's like CS2 didn't do as well as they expected.
So...
Because CS2 didn't do as well as they expected.
And Deadlock right now is like really, really, really popular at the moment.
Despite being like closed invite only.
I'm pretty sure they're just putting all their resources onto...
Onto Deadlock now.
They're just like...
They cut the line on us.
They're like...
Alright, here are all the updates for CS2 that we had going in.
And then they're like...
Alright, let's move all of that...
To Deadlock.
They're just like...
Yeah, they did.
They released CS2 like...
Way too early to try and capitalize hype.
But like...
What was funny was that everybody was opening knife cases and everything.
Knives and everything.
Because they're like...
Oh my god, CS2 is gonna be just like CSGO.
And it's gonna like...
Even increase the knife...
Knife...
Um...
The knife resale value.
But it ended up sort of destroying the economy.
Um...
The knife economy.
Because you know...
CS2...
Destroyed CSGO.
Uh...
Fucked over CSGO.
And then...
Um...
And then the knife economy sort of collapsed.
And now mostly people are trading knives to...
Um...
What was it called?
For embezzlement.
Like...
Is it embezzlement?
What is it called?
When people are like...
Um...
Cause like...
It's like art galleries.
Where people aren't buying the art for the actual art piece.
But they're using it to...
Money laundering!
Yes!
Most like...
Mostly...
The knife economy is...
Is mostly a money laundering scam.
Yeah!
Yeah, you guys didn't know that.
Like that's why some of the knives are incredibly expensive.
Cause they use that to money launder.
Same with art galleries.
People don't really buy...
That's why some art pieces are incredibly expensive.
Because it's all...
It's mostly been like...
For money laundering.
It's not actually for the artwork.
Um...
Yeah.
Haha.
It's crazy.
But yeah.
CS2 sort of destroyed the knife economy.
Because everybody thought...
It like...
Popped the bubble.
The knife bubble.
Uh...
Because people thought it was gonna be the next big thing.
And then...
They ended up releasing the game...
A lot earlier than it should be.
So there are so many things that were missing in CS2.
To a point where like...
People just like...
Didn't care about CS2 anymore.
Anyway.
Uh...
I'm gonna cut it here.
Guys.
Gave you some nice trivia facts there.
But I'm gonna cut it here.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
I just read the...
There's a...
There was no chat here.
So let me...
I'll get...
Put...
I'll keep...
I'll save you guys for just one last second.
There you go.
You guys are live now!
Anyway.
I will see you guys.
Bye!